I had to spoil my recess stop hanging
out with the boys and go meet her in the
recess time because mom said so my dad
dropped me and I saw these girls it was
a girls boarding school so I always saw
all of these those weeping and crying
and my dad expected me to cry and I said
okay now by the moment your parents
leave that's when you realize off people
are crying here first it was a bit
difficult because boys were a bit
confused if they should sit next to me
it was new and exciting and you away
from home but then the homesickness
kicks in a teacher asked in the class
very embarrassing Lee which she
shouldn't have dancing who will be
friends with other tea anytime somebody
got a period it was a celebration so the
principal would come to her personally
and congratulate her there are several
guys who like asked me out and it was
very weird we keep hearing random
stories of women trying funny
experiments okay that test you from the
chemistry lab is missing and you know
why there was a lot of hiding and bushes
in the gym room and it's just every herb
used to get these boys of jelly with
[ __ ] food so at the end we used to trade
with each other saying you give me a
bowl of jelly and I will eat your raw
sabzi tomorrow afternoon we used to have
a tuck shop so like it was junk food and
like chocolates and everything rats was
an under undercover publications and
there was an entire satire written about
teachers and how teachers fight for
positions and among and within
departments to become heads of
department nobody knows till now who
actually published it two friends of
mine were doing it and in the gym on
these mats and the boy jumped off and
the girl tried to jump off but there was
a trampoline there and she jumped off
the trampoline and they thought they got
away with it except she jumped on the
trampoline so she came back up and
teacher saw I think it's just friends
don't change their definitions in your
life don't change you change as a person
my boarding school girlfriends are still
closer to me then we now have best
friends here as well but it's not the
same and it's like like you know the
like my sisters or my brothers we were
that close it was
like family I think we were under the
false belief that we would meet each
other again
we didn't realize the importance of
goodbyes and I think that was good